PROFESSOR: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
We've been talking
in lecture about
various different applications
of definite integrals.
And one of them has been that
we can use definite integrals
to find areas of regions
that previously we
wouldn't have been able to.
So, one simple
example of that is
that we can use a
definite integral
to find the area of a region
bounded between two curves.
So I have an example of
such a question right here.
So the question is to compute
the area of the region that's
bounded between the curves
y equals x cubed and y
equals 3x minus 2.
So one thing you'll notice
is I haven't given you
endpoints for this region.
So I've just given you
the bound and curves.
So one thing you're
going to have to do right
at the beginning is to figure
out what this looks like
and what region you're going
to be integrating over.
What interval you're going
So, this is a kind
of tricky one.
Why don't you pause the
video, think about it
for a few minutes, try
and work it out yourself,
and you can come back and we can
try and work it out together.
All right, welcome back.
So hopefully you've
had some luck
figuring out what this
situation looks like
and then computing the integral.
So let's talk about
it for a minute.
So we have these two curves.
And so somewhere-- I'm asking
about the region bounded
by them-- so what I'm
telling you is somewhere
these curves intercept and they
surround some bounded region.
And so I'm asking for what
the area of that region is.
So in order to
figure that out, we
should figure out where
these curves intercept.
So to find the,
in other words, we
need to find the endpoints of
the interval over which we're
going to integrate.
So in order to that,
we have to solve
for where we have the
intersection between y equals x
cubed and y equals 3x minus 2.
So we have to
solve the equation.
So we need to solve the equation
x cubed equals 3x minus 2.
Or x cubed minus
3x plus 2 equals 0.
So this a polynomial equation.
It's not quadratic, right?
It's a cubic equation.
So that means it's hard
to solve in general.
Luckily in this case,
it's-- there are some--
there's a root we can
recognize fairly easily.
Which is, it's
pretty-- you know,
one thing you can always do is
check small positive integers
or use the rational
root theorem,
if you remember that
from high school math.
So in this case, if
you check x equals 1,
it's fairly easy to
see that x equals
1 is a root of this equation.
So in other words, we can
factor the left-hand side.
We can divide out a
factor of x minus 1.
OK, and so now we have
to do long division
or synthetic division, whatever
kind of division you want,
to divide through here.
So we get x squared minus--
so we've got a-- nope, I lied.
Plus x minus 2 after you divide.
How's that look?
We can just double check.
You know, we get an x cubed
minus x squared plus x squared
minus 2x minus x plus 2.
OK.
So that adds up to
the right thing.
So we either have
that 1 is a root
or that x squared you
know, rather for the places
where these intersect,
we have either x equals 1
or x squared plus
x minus 2 equals 0.
And now here you can,
you know, again factor
or use the quadratic
equation or what have you.
And you can see so we have that
this actually fully factors
as x minus 1 squared
times x plus 2 equals 0.
Which means that we
have intersections
when either x minus 1 is
0 or when x plus 2 is 0.
So intersections at x equals
1 and x equals minus 2.
All right.
So you can take that information
and you can, you know,
put it together and you can
make a nice picture like this.
Or, I suppose, you could
have made the nice picture
before you had that information.
And so we see that we've got
this line, y equals 3x minus 2
here.
And we have the curve
y equals x cubed.
And they have two
intersection points.
They intersect once down
at x equals minus 2,
y equals minus 8.
And they intersect again
up at the point (1, 1).
And they're actually
tangent there.
So x cubed, the curve y equals
x cubed stays above the line
at this point.
So one way you can read
that off is here you
had a double root at
minus 1, if you like.
But, OK, so then, the region in
question is this region here.
So it's a region bounded
between those two curves
that we're trying to
compute the area of.
So now that we
have the endpoints
this isn't such a
tricky problem at all.
Right?
so we've got the endpoints
and we know-- now
that we've drawn this picture--
we know which curve is on top
and which curve is on bottom.
Right?
So the height, when we imagine
cutting this region into lots
of little rectangles or
approximate rectangles,
the height is going to be
x cubed minus 3x minus 2.
Minus the quantity 3x minus 2.
Right?
The x cubed is on top and
3x minus 2 is on the bottom.
So the area is equal
to the integral.
OK, and now we know where we
have to integrate from and to.
So we're integrating from
x equals minus 2 to 1
to get this whole region of
x cubed minus the quantity
3x minus 2 dx.
OK?
Because the y equals x
cubed is the top curve.
And y equals 3x minus
2 is the bottom curve.
So this is the height of those
rectangles, which is positive.
OK, and so now, OK, well now
this is pretty straightforward.
We're integrating a
polynomial at this point.
So this is the integral.
Well, OK, so
integrating x cubed,
that gives me x to
the fourth over 4.
Integrating minus 3x gives
me minus 3x squared over 2.
And integrating plus
2 gives me plus 2x.
Between x equals minus 2 and 1.
So OK, so now I just
do this difference.
So this is equal to 1/4
minus 3/2 plus 2 minus-- OK,
now I put in minus 2 I get 2
to the fourth-- sorry-- minus 2
to the fourth is 16, over
4, so that's minus 4.
OK, minus 3 times 4 over 2 is 6.
And then plus 2 times
minus 2 is minus 4 again.
OK, and now we've just
got some arithmetic.
So this all becomes a plus 6.
And I have to add
everything together.
So that's something like, well
I've got a denominator of 4,
so it's, yeah.
All right, so there's a
secret I should tell you.
Which is that mathematicians
are not actually very
good at arithmetic, usually.
So this is minus 6/4
plus 2 plus 6, so plus 8.
So this is 8 minus 5/4,
which is 6 and 3/4.
OK, that's 6 plus 3/4.
So 6 and 3/4.
This was just arithmetic.
Here was the calculus part.
And, in fact, you know, one
feature of a problem like this
is that you have a fair
amount of work sometimes
to see the picture of
what you're working with.
Then the integration here
was pretty straightforward.
Right?
This was a fairly easy
integral to compute.
If you're, say, better at
fraction arithmetic than I am,
at least.
So, there you go.
So, we had this region.
So we found, actually the
endpoints of the interval.
We found which was the top curve
and which was the bottom curve.
And that led us right
down this integral.
And then that
integral was fairly
easy to compute
from that point out.
And then we ended up with
this as our final area.
So I'll end there.